how do you and I as people who live here
alert you to possible human trafficking
yeah that's always the big question
right it's a big question to a big
problem what can we do to spot human
trafficking the illegal exploitation of
a person Ray Johnson is an assistant
special agent in charge at the FBI Las
Vegas human trafficking in and of itself
involves way more than just the sex
industry nationally the FBI has nearly
1700 open human trafficking cases right
now up from about 700 just last year
according to the National human
trafficking hotline Las Vegas ranks
sixth for the number of calls Nationwide
for help the FBI saying the greatest
number of victims recovered here in the
United States are American citizens the
human trafficking element itself is best
described as modern day slavery forcing
others to do the bidding of someone else
that could mean working for someone who
is forcing you to do a job under the
guise of a better life little to no food
you see folks that are forced to live in
the in the situations they're working in
that's one clue to look for to help
victims you may see them living in the
same place they work or someone else may
be speaking for them they could also be
someone's child missing from one state
brought to live here whether you're here
legally or illegally whether you're here
because you were promised the world and
got nothing for it we need to get you in
a situation where we can help you
Johnson says every FBI field office is
investigating at least one human
trafficking case Las Vegas is no
different more people in a condensed
location gives an opportunity for bad
people to take that that opportunity
against them
the FBI and police all across the
country recently located more than 200
victims in a nationwide operation just
one operation local departments assist
the FBI in its work all leading to state
and federal charges Brian David thank
you and you can always get in touch with
the FBI simply by calling them it's an
easy number to remember 1-800 call FBI
we also have a link to report online at
our website 8newsnow.com